a hundred years ago an estimated 1.5
million Armenians were killed throughout
the Ottoman Empire as World War One took
its toll Turkey object to the term
genocide and successive German
governments have sought to avoid Arau
but from now on the killings will be
referred to as genocide the German
parliament has passed a resolution to
this effect the fate of the Armenians
during World War one is a primary
example in the history of mass murder
ethnic cleansing and the genocides of
the 20th century the move comes just one
day after foreign minister frank-walter
Steinmeier cautioned against damaging
diplomatic ties with Ankara
but cross-party support for the
resolution proved too strong
last week Pope Francis referred to the
events of 1915 as genocide a step
supported by Germany's Protestant church
delvis eccentric on a Kindle I think
this is about acknowledging what
actually happened
by using the term that truly expresses
what happens there we're showing respect
for the victims on Thursday in the
Berlin Cathedral President Joachim Gauck
is expected to refer to the massacres as
genocide for the first time